el Debut Internacional del Rey Carlos
termina en la ciudad alemana de Hamburgo
en el norte del país una ciudad con
vínculos muy estrechos hacia Reino Unido
fue un Debut internacional cargado de
simbolismos fue la primera vez que un
jefe de estado internacional es recibido
con honores militares en la puerta de
brandeburgo uno de los principales
símbolos de Alemania fue la primera vez
que un monarca se dirige en un discurso
ante el pleno del parlamento alemán el
mundo está y además el Rey Carlos lo
hizo parcialmente en alemán para muchos
aquí en Alemania es un honor que el Rey
Carlos haya escogido Alemania como su
primer destino internacional y se espera
que esta visita con todo su simbolismo
pero también con el contenido político
que fue discutido sirva para reforzar y
renovar las relaciones entre Reino Unido
y Alemania que en los últimos años se
vieron afectadas de manera negativa tras
la decisión de Reino Unido de dejar la
Unión europe